bonjour telle une ter-minassian merci
bonjour merci beaucoup pardon d'être en
direct ce matin dans la matinale de
france
le premier ministre sortant nikol
pashinian on vient d'avoir les résultats
est donné vainqueur de ces élections
législatives
il avait remis en cause son mandat on
s'en souvient pour avoir signé la
capitulation face à l'azerbaïdjan qu'est
ce que cela traduit selon vous écoutez
se traduit déjà une première chose c'est
que visiblement l'électorat arménien
reconduit massivement et d'une manière
d'ailleurs un peu inattendu
le gouvernement de la défaite donc je ne
sais pas très bien ce qu'on peut voir en
conclure du point de vue de la
psychologie générale de la société
arménienne l'essai c'est un fait
troublant que ce premier ministre se
soit reconduit dans une proportion qui
l'avait lui-même l'état mais il avait
demandé à ses partisans
une majorité enfin un vote 60 % afin
d'obtenir une majorité confortable au
parlement et afin de gouverner à l'aise
et c'est par une sorte de miracle il
obtient il obtient apparemment plus de
55% des suffrages et et et cela semble
tout à fait miraculeux c'est à cet
instant fabuleux et inattendu qui ne
traduisent pas l'état de division de la
société arménienne depuis cette
fracassante des fêtes cette
spectaculaire défaite qui a conduit à la
signature du cessez-le-feu je rappelle
que l'azerbaïdjan a en effet attaqué
l'arménie le 27 septembre 2020 et que et
que donc le gouvernement à chiner en
bonne logique aurait dû au moins et
essuie n'est pas le cas donc tout pour
que ces tentatives
je n'explique pas plus que ça parce
qu'il faut bien savoir que jusqu'ici les
sondages
pour autant qu'on puisse évidemment ce
sondage donnait le contrat civique de
pachinian et tha chin crâne le bloc
arménie de coach ayant quasiment au
coude à coude aux alentours chacun d'un
peu plus 20 20 de plus de 20%
voilà que l'écart est absolument énorme
et de pachinian vente est bien au-delà
de 55 % des voix tandis que le bloc le
bloc d'arménie lui du de l'ex président
robert kotcharian se trouve aux
alentours de 20% pour autant qu'on le
sache pas ce que les chiffres sont très
variables d'une estimation
alors ces dissensions et elles vont
peut-être perdurer la crainte même
peut-être de nouvelles violences puisque
robert que coach arian lui parle de
fraude et le premier ministre sortant
donné vainqueur lui appelle à se
rassembler à erevan la capitale ce soir
là
que peut-on affectivement oui alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que alors c'est
un fait d'ailleurs un peu troublant mais
nikol pashinian avaient déjà réservé la
place de la république pour un meeting
ce soir les semble-t-il aussi pour deux
ou trois jours pour les deux ou trois
jours qui viennent ce qui comme l état
peu troublant quand même que le résultat
des ne soit on attend avant même
d'ailleurs sept ans et été organisées
mais admettons de toute façon il
n'aurait sans doute faire un meeting
avec ses avec ses partisans gotha robert
kotcharian
pour autant que je sache et ce qui a été
publié en place sur la page facebook de
son de sa formation il déclaré en effet
mais de manière assez pont dès que les
résultats publiés de l'élection
parlementaire sont sujets à controverse
et peu crédible il contraste dit-il
fortement avec les différentes
manifestations de la vie publique auquel
nous avons assisté pendant les huit
derniers mois
les résultats des sondages y compris
des internationaux et finalement ces
résultats défie le bon sens bon mais ça
ça n'est pas ça c'est une remarque
générale ça je n'en tire pas pour
conclusion que robert kotcharian a
immédiatement procédé à la contestation
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs ce que cela ce
que cela comporte comme vérifications
techniques en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que lors de son meeting
vendredi soir c'était le dernier meeting
de la campagne il avait en effet mis en
garde à ses partisans contre la
possibilité des fraudes dans le comptage
des voix
durant la nuit que nous venons de passer
et moi je suis incapable je suis
incapable de vous dire s'il ya fraude ou
lourd j'ai passé la journée il y à
courir dans les pires au de vote j'ai
assisté au dépouillement
tout semblait normal enfin en pratique
et d'ailleurs je dois dire que j'étais
dans un bureau d'un dans le centre de
lima nous ou au contraire c'était les
mains de robert kotcharian ensemble et
en fibres en vente
donc je mon commentaire est un petit peu
je suis un peu troublé est en effet
beaucoup avaient prédit que ses
résultats seraient de kits manière
contestée et donc on plonge je ne suis
pas cassandre je pense que l'on est un
peu prudent de rassembler dans une sous
tension dénis team en tout cas s'ils
doivent avoir lieu à répétition parce
que les adversaires et surtout s'ils se
considèrent comme des adversaires crispé
de frustrés de leur bol d'or noir oui ça
pourrait mal tourner et je le souhaite
évidemment
merci beaucoup tallinn termine à sion de
nous avoir livré ce matin votre analyse
en direct d
evans et on va suivre évidemment
l'évolution de la situation
merci beaucoup